[Applauso]
[Musica]
sono sempre stata disordinata mio padre
mi ha sempre sgridata per questo nella
mia cameretta non si trovava mai niente
decide di fogli sulla scrivania fra
punti scolastici e spartiti musicali la
chitarra sempre sul letto e i vestiti
sulla sedia
il mio disordine ho sempre trovato tutto
forse perché conoscevo la perfezione la
disposizione delle cose
in realtà
sono sempre stata fuori dall'ordine
dallo standard anche nello sviluppo
abbiamo solo otto anni quando mi sono
arrivate le mestruazioni
il mio corpo cambiava e con lui anche lo
sguardo della società
era iniziato ufficialmente il processo
di sessualizzazione del mio corpo le
mestruazioni nella vita di una donna
vengono percepite proprio in questo modo
quando ti arrivano diventi signorina e
quando vanno via il tuo corpo smette di
essere sessualizzato
La cosa strana è che in realtà mi sono
sempre sentita come una affittuaria per
spiegarmi meglio avevo come la
sensazione che il mio corpo fosse un
oggetto non mio di cui devo prendere
cura per gli altri non per me
non metterti la gang è troppo stretti
che ti mettono in evidenza le cosce
grandi
non metterti maglie troppo scollate che
con quel seno sei volgare
un truccarti tanto sono chissà cosa
penserà la gente di te
Mi raccomando non metterti nulla che ti
evidenzia la pancia più morbido è meglio
soprattutto se è nero sai snellisce
la società mi ha insegnato fin da subito
che il mio corpo per essere considerato
valido doveva seguire una serie di
regole ben precise
perché la bellezza viene percepita come
un valore morale che stabilisce quanto
il tuo corpo sia meritevole di rispetto
da parte degli altri
Ma che cos'è la bellezza
so chiaramente stabilire quello che è il
canone attualmente in vigore un po' come
se fosse legge ma non so dare una
definizione oggettiva analitica di
bellezza
probabilmente in questo momento me lo
sarete chiedendo anche voi e sono
convinta che la maggior parte sta
pensando a qualcosa di completamente
astratto e non ha tutte quelle regole
che cerchiamo di seguire tutti i giorni
per entrare in quello standard
ma davvero devo seguire quelle regole
Come potrò mai somigliare ad una top
model mi servirebbe sicuramente un pezzo
di gamba in più un tot di chili in meno
e chissà quante altre cose di cui per
fortuna in questo momento non mi sto
rendendo conto
E se lo infrango consapevolmente
Se scelgo di vivere nel mio disordine
cosa potrebbe succedere
la società proverebbe a rimettermi al
mio posto ad infilarmi nella gabbia
dorata firmata dal patriarcato nella
quale vivono tutte le donne
Infatti siamo tutte vittime di quella
che possiamo chiamare pressione estetica
il nostro corpo ci appartiene davvero
siamo davvero libere di scegliere quello
che è più giusto per noi no
dobbiamo essere belle Prima di tutto
belle non un unico modo eh le vostre
definizioni personali in questo
paradigma Non sono ammesse possiamo
essere persino dell'astronauta nello
spazio ma se non rispettiamo Lo standard
di bellezza non saremo mai delle donne
abbastanza valide
la società ci chiede di essere delle
belle piante d'arredamento che non
necessitano di troppa cura
intelligenti abbastanza ma non troppo
estremamente attenti all'estetica ma
senza esserne appassionate se no è un
attimo che diventiamo delle oche che
pensano solo i trucchi al parrucchiere
negli ultimi anni è sempre più alla moda
la bellezza naturale
sono milioni tutorial che troviamo
online che ci insegnano a truccare il
nostro viso seguendo le regole del make
up no make up
un trend che vive in una
contrapposizione dal principio se ci
pensiamo
il trucco non deve sembrare artificiale
ma per essere realizzato utilizza i
prodotti che coprono le discromie
naturali della pelle
le occhiaie Naturalmente un po'
grigiastre
infoltiscono ma non troppo la Sicilia
naturalmente non lunghe tre metri e con
le giuste luci le giuste ombre alzano
palpebre e zigomi naturalmente cadenti
e dopo più di mezz'ora passata a
truccarci per sembrare struccate ma
fresche come delle Rose Siamo pronte per
uscire a fare la passerella al centro
commerciale
dove probabilmente acquisteremo altri
prodotti di bellezza Infatti i dati ci
dicono che l'80% dei prodotti che
Vengono venduti al mondo sono acquistati
da donne Ma io mi chiedo quanti di
questi prodotti che mensilmente entrano
nelle nostre case hanno lo scopo di
renderci più belle
Quanti soldi e quanto tempo spendiamo al
mese per estetista parrucchiere moda e
make up ve lo dico io non mi do nemmeno
il tempo di pensare più del dovuto
la pressione estetica
non è solamente
un gigantesco peso psicologico che ci
portiamo addosso come un accessorio
scomodo di ingombrante Ma a tutti gli
effetti un enorme business che agisce
secondo delle regole di genere
Ok questa è la Tosta Facciamo un gioco
immaginiamo un mondo in cui
all'improvviso e intendo proprio dal
giorno alla notte
tutte le donne
smettono di pensare costantemente alla
propria estetica e di acquistare
prodotti di bellezza
Che mondo sarebbe
chiudete gli occhi immaginatelo solo per
un secondo
fatto
molto probabilmente dopo il crollo del
fatturato di moltissime multinazionali
le donne sarebbero più concentrate e
forse smetterebbero anche di paragonare
costantemente i loro corpi con quelli
delle altre donne con le quali
condividono lo spazio della stanza
mi succedeva molto spesso quando ero
ragazzina e ogni tanto mi succede ancora
oggi
ero a scuola seduta al mio banco
stavo ascoltando interessata alla
lezione così da studiare meno a casa
e all'improvviso mi rendo conto di
essermi perso un pezzo del discorso
perché il mio pensiero Era volato verso
il paragone dei miei capelli
con quelli della mia compagna di classe
bionda e liscia
risultato
un profondo senso di inadeguatezza e
Mirò pure bene Sei un pezzo di lezione
che poi Avrei dovuto recuperare a casa
sui libri
fallimento critico
l'ossessione per la bellezza Infatti ci
distrae in moltissimi ambiti della
nostra vita
nella sfera sessuale le donne non si
godono il momento per imitare la
bellezza pornografica un po' come se
fosse una performance
per arrivare in ordine al lavoro ci
dobbiamo svegliare molto prima dei
nostri colleghi uomini per acconciarci
truccarci vestirci con abiti molto più
scomodi
e grande parte di quello che saranno il
nostro stipendio che ricordo Grazie al
gender PayPal statistica inferiore a
quello maschile Grazie grazie mille
andrà speso in prodotti che foraggiano
quell'industria che crea elucra sulle
nostre insicurezze
è per questo e per infiniti altri motivi
che vedo nella pressione estetica una
delle più grandi ingiustizie del nostro
secolo
sogno un mondo libero dagli standard di
bellezza
non voglio entrare nelle vostre regole
impossibili e patinate voglio creare
disordine con il mio corpo
voglio occupare spazio e rivendicare il
mio tempo senza per questo subire una
serie di discriminazioni sistemiche che
non fanno altro che incasellare i corpi
in categorie di serie A e categorie di
serie Z
ed è inevitabile per me
pensare a quella ragazzina che ha 15
anni suonava la chitarra su un letto in
una stanza perennemente incasinata
mille sogni in testa e altrettante paure
il senso di non essere mai abbastanza
che caratterizza l'adolescenza o la vita
di chi come me soffre della sindrome
dell'impostore
pensa lei e a quanto ha sofferto per un
corpo che non aveva nulla di sbagliato
Pensa tutta la rabbia che si è fatta e
che avrebbe voluto urlare e poi penso a
me che sono ancora lei ma che oggi sono
qui e su questo palco creo disordine e
davanti a voi le do voce
[Applauso]
ho lo scopo di allontanare anche solo
una di voi da quella che l'ossessione
per la bellezza ma ne basta davvero solo
una per rendermi felice perché sono
convinta che sia all'improvviso e
intendo proprio dal giorno alla notte
tutte le donne smettessero di pensare
costantemente alla propria estetica Il
mondo non sarebbe un posto più brutto ma
noi saremo sicuramente più libere Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]